[Música]
bordeado por sus castillos suntuosos
congelados en el tiempo se le conoce
como el río real con su vista para
quedar sin aliento hacia joyas
arquitectónicas del Renacimiento
pero el río ofrece también la
posibilidad de escaparse de acercarse a
la naturaleza y de un patrimonio más
desconocido Es agradable hay una linda
vista
Esta quietud es lo que buscan
uno no se cruza con nadie estamos en
vacaciones
no hay ruido en lugares ideal bucólico
uno se abstrae solo alegría Es cierto
que estamos en el elemento y es muy
agradable estas dos turistas alquilaron
estas bicicletas por cinco días una
manera de descubrir esta linda región a
su ritmo pagamos para sudar
Hay que ser masoquista escucha si al
cabo de cinco días pierdo 10 kilos está
perfecto para mí
en bicicleta es posible desde 2006 tras
la inauguración de una red de ciclos
rutas especialmente trazadas para el
cicloturismo a lo largo del río desde
entonces el éxito crece y hace feliz a
los pueblos de la región en temporada en
modo entre tours y samuú dominicraclean
abrió recientemente el primer ciclo café
a orillas del loaag un concepto que
copió de los ingleses
hace dos años llegué de Londres hay 250
ciclos cafés en el centro de la ciudad
tan solo uno a orillas en bicicleta
y el concepto funciona bien repara
alquila 20 componentes y hace las veces
de restaurantes
somos tres establecimientos hay una
panadería un pequeño hotel restaurante
cigarrería y yo
por supuesto ella impulsó nuestra
facturación el cicloturismo a orillas
equivale a más de un millón de personas
en bicicleta cada año Pero existe un
medio más tranquilo para descubrir el
río
en champú una asociación local propone
embarcarse en una embarcación plana
este tipo de embarcación tradicional
servía para la pesca de salmón ahora se
usa para paseos turísticos una salida en
el Crepúsculo que ofrece nuevas
perspectivas sobre las riquezas del río
cuando se está en el río hay otro punto
de vista Esto es lo que me gusta en mi
trabajo es eso es a la vez transmitirle
un mensaje a la gente con respecto al
medio ambiente o los métodos de consumo
pero también hacer descubrir con
frecuencia se tienen ganas de comprar un
tiquete para ir a otro lugar pero
también tenemos muchas cosas aquí
es magnífico estoy contenta de haber
tenido un poco de sol porque el cielo
estaba muy gris y temía no poder ver la
puesta del sol aquí tenemos los lindos
colores de la puesta del sol un paseo
intemporal posible gracias al Astillero
naval mantenido por una asociación
ubicada en mule
estás perforando recuerda mover hacia
arriba aquí construimos embarcaciones
con el mismo saber hacer del siglo XIX
una quincena de remolcadores como este
salieron de desde su creación en el 2013
construir un barco es algo un poco
mágico estamos fabricando una gran
embarcación plana
cuando la ponemos sobre el agua algo
ocurre cuando la vemos llegar al agua es
la hora de la verdad nos damos cuenta de
que el barco flota
vemos un monumento posarse sobre el agua
lo cual es la concretización de varios
meses de trabajo un trabajo realizado
por hombres y mujeres en inserción un
deseo del creador de la asociación
trabajamos en buenas condiciones en
cuanto a calor humano
me enseñaron a hacer arreglos no sabía
hacerlo es enriquecedor una vez
terminada esta embarcación plana fue
llevada a un hotel de lujo cercano de
chambó es posible pasar una noche mágica
en el río
pero el medio más auténtico para
descubrirlo a es tal vez la Canoa
desde hace más de 10 años Jean Franco
guía y fotógrafo les propone a los
turistas una fórmula Canoa y campamento
[Música]
en la pequeña embarcación se recorre un
log más íntimo más salvaje también
el look de las Islas
[Música]
conduce a unas 50 personas al año entre
abril y octubre hacia una desconexión
total
la gente trata de relajarse con respecto
a la vida de todos los días los horarios
etcétera
se trata de evasión naturaleza
[Música]
los campamentos son tolerados gianfram
aprovecha para cuidar este entorno a un
conservado
La idea evidentemente es no quemar los
árboles solo usar madera muerta Cuando
se llega a la isla recogemos
La idea es irse dejando una isla más
limpia que la que vivimos
antes de dormir en la carpa cónica unas
cuantas salchichas asadas en un barbecue
una alegría en plena naturaleza Este es
un pequeño vino rosado del chef
sí no muy lejos de la gente que va a los
castillos existe un lock paralelo
más auténtico y menos turístico
una vida real hacia la serenidad